hey youtubers is Charlie so big news
about thor ragnarok in the future of
thor in the marvel universe so have a
couple theories about what's going on
with him as of Doctor Strange in the
director was actually saying a couple
funny things about what he's doing with
the Thor movie that's like vastly
different from previous Thor movies
important stuff first so there's a rumor
that we're going to see a Thor
post-credit scene at the end of Doctor
Strange they'll be like a couple
post-credit scenes the Thor one will be
like the big one teasing the next big
Marvel movie because Thor is coming next
year there are three Marvel movies
though guardians of the galaxies in the
spring spider-man is in the summer and
then Thor is happening around this time
around November when Doctor Strange is
coming out next year so the timelines a
little confusing if they're going to use
that outdoor scene that we saw earlier
this year they were filming where Thor
has like a little card that has dr.
Strange's address on it what does that
mean for the Thor movie because it looks
like Doctor Strange is going to help
them with Odin like the homeless version
of Odin that's been wandering around on
earth but if that's all happening before
the Thor movie starts then what does
that say about the plot of the Thor
movie that's like a whole other thing
but the idea is like the big rumor like
even bigger than the idea that we're
gonna see Thor at the end of Doctor
Strange is the conditions on which
Doctor Strange helps them so supposedly
Doctor Strange says something like I'll
help you find your hobo Odin but only on
the condition that all as Guardians
leave Earth permanently like Earth is
off-limits to everyone from Asgard both
Loki and Thor now of course you'd want
to ban Loki from Earth he's nothing but
mischief but banning Thor from Earth is
a huge deal what does that say about
future Marvel films what they might be
doing is is using this as an opportunity
to transition Thor away from like the
main Avengers films into a more Robert
Downey jr. type role where he just guest
stars from time to time but they have an
easy way of explaining how the future
Thor movies can just kind of be off by
themselves like the guardians of the
galaxy movies in outer space because we
do know that the Thor movie is only
going to briefly take place on earth
most of it's going to be like a buddy
road trip with Hulk in outer space but
the thing is is the director of thor
ragnarok has said a couple things about
how he's just kind of tried to do his
own thing ignore what the other Marvel
movies are doing do his best to give
like the most amazing unique retro
experience I'll talk about that in a
second but make the Thor movies cool
again because dark world was better than
the first Thor movie but still on the
list of Marvel movies so far it doesn't
rank super high on the list so they're
aiming to change that with Thor Ragnarok
in in order to do that in order to do
something new that they haven't done
before
they're just transitioning away from
Earth which i think is a smart move
because it gives them such a bigger
sandbox to play in and you've already
got all these other earth-based
characters that you're getting ready to
introduce in their own movies like black
panther spider-man Captain Marvel all
earth-based characters so it makes sense
that you would like transition some of
the classic Avengers away if you could
in Thor is one of the few space-based
characters like guardians of the galaxy
so why not just let him exist in space
in his movies but I love the idea of a
scene between Benedict Cumberbatch and
Tom Hiddleston where by Doctor Strange
tells Loki to GTFO but let me know in
the comments what do you think the idea
of Thor being banned from Earth by
Doctor Strange says about the future of
Thor in the Marvel Universe I'm assuming
that Chris Hemsworth will resign his
contract but it just provides some
interesting twists for the character in
his future should they choose to go down
that path but Kevin Feige said that they
always have like a bunch of different
plans if things don't work out like
originally Spiderman wasn't supposed to
be in Civil War black panther was gonna
be a much bigger character but when they
got spider-man they're like okay we'll
go with our plan a but we had Plan B and
Plan C if those things didn't work out
so they have like a plan a plan B Plan C
for Thor Chris Hemsworth should he
choose to not reassign his contract but
I think he totally will he makes too
much money has way too much fun making
these movies to walk away so I think
he'll just transition to a Robert Downey
jr. type role if they choose to not make
more solo films and you'll see like the
full extent of that when we get to
spider-man homecoming like look at the
way they use Robert
Jr in that movie very briefly but a very
awesome guest appearance so they could
always use Thor in that way especially
if he becomes king of Asgard that would
give him a big reason to not come to
earth because he would have so many more
problems that Odin would normally be
dealing with which they might do at the
end of the Thor movie that's still kind
of up in the air it depends on where
they want the Thor character to be at
the beginning of infinity war but yet
night it's gonna be awesome and be sure
and go see Doctor Strange in the movie
theater so you actually get to see that
Thor scene or at least confirm some of
the twists it's gonna look like no other
Marvel movie you've ever seen before and
like it's you know the director of Thor
Ragnarok saying that he's gonna make
Thor cool again super retro experience
so remember that funny Thor trailer that
they released for the Civil War DVD it
was like the comic-con Thor trailer they
showed up so it has that retro VHS intro
Marvel redesigned all their movie logos
to look 80s retro so when he says a
retro movie he's talking about 80s style
storytelling as well as some of the
visual cues that you see from the 80s
like VHS is just like a really big 80s
thing but make no mistake they are
filming the Thor movie like the most
expensive advanced cameras that exist
right now this is a picture of the rig
that they were using for one particular
shot these are five plus of the most
expensive cameras that you can use
synced together for a single scene
meaning that it's probably like a big
Ragnarok action set piece like
full-blown Odin versus the Ragnarok
monsters but just a heads up tonight
Superman and Supergirl laying the
beatdown on metallo I'll post that video
after it airs there's a bunch of DC
stuff happening this week a bunch of
Marvel TV stuff too so I'll try and post
that as quick as possible where you guys
wait for that to post you can click here
to watch that funny thor trailer again
and you can click here for the last big
Doctor Strange trailer thank you so much
for watching everybody let's high five
I'll see you guys tonight